walk in to this video I'm playing pepper
Bob from the US let's see not that one
against the Banco usually should go 93
or ignore c5 let's same hmm yeah that's
that's a bit weird what is doing
especially ed e5 look Sam very tricky
already 5v5 g-form takes at Queenie to
check winning a PM this type of tactic
ifsc numerous times already are
interesting but if if I go just Bishop
e2 and he moves this night i'm going to
take d5 right isn't this very
problematic yeah this is just a piece on
95 just a moment 95 yeah why not why not
wow I'm piece up and I have three pieces
developed vs no peace this is quite
quite something don't don't see that too
often mmm should g5 I mean okay winning
here in more than one way actually I
guess but how to do it castles rookie
want all very nice Bishop g5 iz neias
the check is this is good they all look
they all look good no cam come on let's
castle rookie one is really a quite
quite a thread okay let's just keep it
simple yeah maybe here 56 I mean there
are many moves check
check
okay still can cancel right he has not
moved the kingdom some of course
important let's see pre g-form love to
get queen a foreign but it's not so not
so easy hmm
okay maybe that one Queen B 2 rupee one
who p7 I mean okay I didn't play the
best possible way but it still looks
disastrous yeah I think you couldn't
they couldn't take really let's um let's
see Quinn age 5 24 now come on let's
break this up if you move if he takes
with the Queen rupee one would be seven
it takes with the call i'm going to take
deform yeah click deform yeah that he
studies through that this game is still
going on that's not a good sign I really
played this terribly should have been
over long ago okay let's see your cue on
I should be able to get the beep on
I really don't know sometimes yeah I
simply didn't pay any attention after
this opening I mean now now you really
should pay attention all the time
sometimes is some a bit tricky if you
really am winning and absolutely every
way there's no way not to win besides
what I played I guess it's quite quite
funny that he's playing in a fashion
that is actually not so clear at all
check yeah still this is still going on
and I have plundered the whole look
basically okay it's trying to to get the
deep on going check not going to allow
that so easy so easily
check no he does not have any parts left
and i forgot the h-bomb oh yeah well
yeah fnh porn is supposed to be a draug
quite often but i don't think this is
one of those those positions black
resigns yeah well this is some new low I
really have a speechless around here I
really thought okay let's get this over
with and I it's it's really totally
winning what the heck did I do I mean
what did i do when this cannot be too
bad it's just plus a DM and Connie to
the comp okay this is not the best but
jacket store check Bishop g5 is good him
yeah I had a thought about this briefly
but I couldn't really make it work this
f6e on this chase I can take with the
night I forgot about that this is
winning yeah of course is winning but I
didn't see it okay yeah now I'm hmm it
starts to get a bit strange already just
got two pawns now he's got two points
for the piece it's still winning but not
so clearly winning us before camp and
here prepare smack we going I simply add
simply a miscounted here with route
before then but i have actually have
still have the smooth it's probably
still okay for what
I simply didn't didn't didn't look at
night at 5i can just go here and there's
nothing nothing going on really it's the
only two pawns yeah yeah this was just
far too superficially plate now I'm just
I'm just dead lost I really don't know
what what what was what is happening
here why wasn't wasn't here winning well
I hear some here's a way to do it that's
that's now that's not completely trivial
yeah I have it should be winning but
naughty not so easy you can know yeah
and step step by step I mean after that
it's it's not clear no not at all okay
okay for us strong yeah okay for as a
good move I cannot prevent deform yeah
it's still winning it really was a
number number of mistakes and overall
just a very bad game or what what can
you do Wow okay thanks for watching
anyway must be like I don't know looking
at the train wreck or something well
thanks for watching